pénurie de sang dans les hôpitaux les
médecins tirent la sonnette d'alarmé
les réserves de sont dangereusement
baissé en france les dons de sang sont
insuffisants chaque année c'est le même
problème
la france est en manque de sang des
stocks au plus bas des donneurs qui
désertent les centres de dons pourtant
dès les années 60 il y avait des
campagnes de sensibilisation
pensez aux vies humaines que vous pouvez
sauver en donnant votre sans penser que
peut être vous même un jour aurait
besoin du sang des autres
malgré des appels du pied du milieu
médical la france est continuellement en
manque de dons alors la faute à qui en
1968 cette femme déploré le manque
d'informations et de renseignements je
n'ai pas encore donné messieurs mais je
donnerai certainement
et cette année ferme
comment expliquer que peu de personnes
donnent leur sang après je pense qu'on
n'est pas assez sollicités au début des
années 90 la france fait face à l'un des
plus gros scandales sanitaires de son
histoire
l' affaire du sang contaminé les
donneurs prennent peur et désert de les
centres de dons l' affaire du sang
contaminé et y est pour quelque chose
c'est sûr mais bon je vois pas pourquoi
dans la mesure où on utilise toujours
des aiguilles stériliser chaque personne
donc il ya aucune raison de malgré les
contrôles et un risque nul pour les
donneurs
le nombre de dons diminuent passant de
près de deux millions trois cent trente
quatre mille en 1999 à 2 millions 176000
en 2005 en 2006 il augmente enfin pour
atteindre près de deux millions deux
cent quinze mille si j'annonçais pour
montrer l'exemple
petit à petit les français reviennent
dans les centres en 2012 le nombre de
dons du sang atteignant un peu plus de 2
millions 600 mille avant de diminuer une
nouvelle fois cette année là le docteur
bruno danic tiré la sonnette d'alarmé à
la projet vacances d'été on a besoin de
600 dons par jour pour faire face aux
besoins en hématologie pour traiter des
cancers pour traiter des interventions
chirurgicales mais il est aussi
nécessaire pour faire face à toute
situation en 2018
seuls 4% des français avaient donné leur
sang un chiffre bien trop faible par
rapport à une demande toujours plus
forte
selon l'établissement français du sang
les niveaux de réserves de sang sont
critiques
à tel point qu'ils sont au plus bas
depuis 2011
[Musique]